mutual desire is normally signaled by a
pretty weird act to organs otherwise
used for eating and speaking are rubbed
and pressed against one another with
increasing force accompanied by the
secretion of saliva a tongue normally
precisely manipulated to articulate
vowel sounds or to push mashed potato or
broccoli to the rear of the palate now
moves forward to meet its counterpart
whose tip it might touch and repeated
staccato movements one would have to
carefully explain to an alien visitor
from Kepler 9b what's going on they're
not about to bite chunks out of each
other's cheeks or attempting to inflate
one another why is kissing so
significant and potentially so exciting
sexual excitement is psychological it's
not so much what our bodies happen to be
doing that's getting us turned on it's
what's happening in our imaginations
that matters partly the excitement of
kissing is the result of social codes
being breached we could imagine a
society where it was very forbidden and
yet very special for two people to rub
the gap between the index finger and
thumb together the first time you did it
would be something you'd remember all
your life the huge meaning of kissing is
something we've built up by social
agreement and it's fundamental
definition is I accept you enough to do
something potentially quite revolting
with you the inside of a mouth is deeply
private ordinarily it would be utterly
nauseating to have a stranger poke their
tongue into your face to allow someone
to do these things signals a fundamental
level of acceptance all of us suffer
from strong feelings of shame which
another's kiss starts to work on
overcoming aside from our public
identities we all have lonely a private
selves which is what we feel we're
getting and giving access to through a
kiss our mouths become privileged arenas
in which to surrender our defenses and
gift ourselves to another physical
pleasure aside
that's why it's so very exciting
you